[Applause]
Vanderbilt University professor and
author of dying of whiteness how the
politics of racial resentment is killing
America's heartland Jonathan Metzl
Jonathan so you wrote a very interesting
book we've heard before that the Trump
voter votes against his own economic
interest but you're taking in a quite a
bit further and you're saying that Trump
policies actually make it more likely
that the mostly white male voter who is
the Trump core voter is going to get
sick and die well I mean I'm a professor
and I'm and I'm a doctor right and I
made too and and so you know basically
the core argument of the book is that
the politics that claim to make white
America great again wrote end up making
particularly working-class white lives
harder sicker and in many instances
shorter I spent about seven years going
through the South where I live and
tracking the story of basically what
happens if you live in a state that for
example blocks healthcare reform that
lets anybody and everyone by a decade
expand Medicaid expansion blocking
expanding lives yeah huge tax cuts that
end up undercutting roads bridges and
schools and what I found was on one hand
that gave many people the sensation of
winning but when I looked at it from a
medical angle and from a data angle
those policies themselves ended up being
as dangerous to people and particularly
working-class white people as asbestos
or secondhand smoke are not wearing
seatbelts and cars they were literally
contributing to a shortened life span
and guns too right I mean when the gun
laws relax aren't there more white
suicides I mean that was one of the more
surprising things I spent a lot of time
in Missouri and really really painful
powerful you know I would go to NRA
meeting as I sat in on support group
meetings for people who who lost loved
ones for suicide there's nothing nothing
more painful and more sad but the issue
that I found was when you when you make
the gun laws very lacks and it
tickler state it seems like it's just
about you know letting people
concealed-carry are open carry all this
come things but there's this filter down
effect in which all other kinds of
shootings become more prominent so there
were more accidental shootings more
partner shootings more police shootings
but the real shootings that skyrocketed
were the deaths of white men basically
white men were about white we're to the
deaths right white men commit suicide
yeah ways that minorities don't is that
true I mean basically you know we have
about forty thousand gun deaths a year
in this country
and two-thirds of those deaths are are
suicides and of that the numbers of
white male suicides it's like 80% 85%
why did why a white men kill themselves
I've spent a lot of time there man don't
I mean partially it's that white men own
a lot of guns and particularly in rural
areas where people are feeling isolated
and factors like that so I but I also
think that you know I found these
remarkable stories of people who the gun
was their protector it was there to
protect them but in these moments of
despair you know they got fired they you
know lost their job they found out their
wife was having affair or something like
that in that moment this thing that's
supposed to be a protector ends up being
the most lethal thing you could have in
the room and so again and again when I
talk to families this thing that was
like the symbol of white of white
Authority became its undoing very lethal
did have anything to do with the fact
also that maybe as they went through
life they had white privilege to some
degree not that everyone what white life
is easy it certainly is not especially
in rural areas but they never faced the
kind of hardship that minorities faced
more routinely when the [ __ ] hit the fan
boom I certainly think that that's
absolutely true in a particular way
which is in other words I heard I heard
a lot of people talking to me about you
know whiteness under attack and white
kind of white despair because of
immigrants and minorities and I did want
to kind of say the same thing even
though I was there as a researcher I
kept thinking well there are a lot of
people in your state who actually have
it a lot worse than you but that being
said I do they don't want to hear that
but but I also there's something very
particular about white male guns suicide
which is that on one hand it's
incredibly prevalent and prominent and
the other hand there's this huge
knowledge gap nobody talks about it if
you listen to the NRA for example they
say you need guns because of carjackers
and gangbangers and all
kind of things and even researchers like
myself there's a huge gap in knowledge
because there's been a federal ban on
gun research and so we don't even know I
mean many many white Americans own guns
what predicts which one's gonna turn the
gun on themselves and the honest answer
if anybody tells you this the honest
answer is we don't know but it's not the
government's job to prevent suicide is
it well I mean the issue again of course
there's no responsibility despondency
can't also be part of the portfolio guns
yeah guns is an interesting case about
that right because there's this long
history of gun ownership and people are
very proud of it and so I don't I would
never want to say that I was gonna take
somebody's gun or that we should but it
was interesting to see that these it was
just suicide was an unintended
consequence the gun on this form of I
think if an attachment of white pride
you know that it's a it's a sort of a
cultural identity thing now I mean
that's an yeah I mean I feel like in
America now white people are either
self-loathing the Liberals are you know
they're white so lame and and you know
the unbearable being of whiteness and
then and the Trump people are the
opposite you know they actually think
reverse racism is a worse problem they
there's no middle ground there's no like
sensible whiteness
you